[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood vol
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne
and goes on to recount the generations
of targaryens who fought to hold that
iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the yatana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon
iii's reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert cervellian attended targaryen
dynasty
robert's rebellion also known as the war
of the usurper
was a rebellion against house targaryen
primarily instigated by eric stark jon
irene and robert baratheon
for whom it's named it lasted close to a
year
and resulted in the end of the targaryen
dynasty in the seven kingdoms
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and
executive producers george r martin will
also serve as executive producer
one of the main characters from this
time period was rehgar targaryen
prince rhaegar targaryen the last prince
of dragonstone was the eldest son
and heir to king garys the second
targaryen the mad king by his sister
wife queen ryla targaryen
having features of old valyrian rhaegar
had deep purple eyes and silver blonde
hair
as a child he read obsessively to the
point that jests were made about his
habits
he became a noted warrior later in life
although he did not initially seem
inclined
to martial habits however apparently by
something he had read
rhaegar became motivated to become a
warrior
rehgar was the older brother of viserys
and daenerys targaryen
and husband of felia martel with whom he
had two children
rhaenys and aegon he also fathered jon
snow with lyanna stark
whom he secretly married following an
annulment from alien
aerys says the second reign began with
great promise
but as years passed he slid deeper and
deeper into insanity and paranoia
the shift was gradual and he frequently
recovered
by the time it became severe prince
rhaegar already showed such great
promise as the future heir to the throne
that most were willing to endure aerys's
eccentricities
intending to wait out the remainder of
his reign
until rehgar succeeded him rhaegar was
brave kind and wise
and most looked forward to the golden
era that would assuredly begin
when he would ascend to the throne
greatly troubled by aerys is the second
growing insanity rhaegar was torn
between weather to act against him or
not
but could not bring himself to turn
against his own father
at court there was growing tension
between factions loyal to the king
and to the prince grand maester pycelle
dispatched a letter to the citadel
writing that tensions and division at
court strongly resembled
those before the dance of the dragons by
still was fearful a targaryen civil war
would break out
unless some accord could be reached that
would satisfy both factions
like the rest of the realm rhaegar hoped
to simply wait out the rest of his
father's reign
and that his bouts of insanity would
remain manageable by his courtiers
rhaegar had good reason to think that a
small council could keep the realm
together
despite his father's madness as it was
very capably led by timing lannister
who served as darius's hand for nearly
20 years
taiwan was not only able to keep aries
from tearing the realm apart
but managed royal affairs so well that
he brought two decades of peace and
plenty for westeros
to the point that most people throughout
the realm were unaware of king's madness
until the final years of his reign many
assumed that in reward for tywin's long
and distinguished service says
heirs's chief advisor the bond between
the targaryens and lannisters would
eventually be solidified with a marriage
alliance between prince rhaegar
and tywin's daughter cersei yetery
surprisingly spurned the match
saying that tywin was still just a
servant and should not try to elevate
his family above its station
as such a match was beneath rhaegar
aerys instead agreed to an arranged
marriage between rehgar and
alien martell a princess from dorne
daughter of the ruling princess of dorne
who was a distant cousin of the royal
line through intermarriage a century
before
rehgar in elia's marriage was happy
according to all accounts
rhaegar nalia had two children a
daughter named rhaenys and then a son
named aegon
mr raymond whom rhaegar corresponded via
raven messages
remembers that rhaegar believed his
child aegon to be the prince that was
promised
a few years later the great tourney at
harrenhal was held
and all the prominent lords of westeros
assembled during the figgis
rhaegar played a song on his harp so
beautiful and sorrowful
that it moved even the wild she-wolf
liana stark to tears
the exact events that happened in
private are unknown
but the public events that attorney's
final joust are known to all
regard one during the great tourney at
hancol rhaegar seemed unstoppable
and defeated even sir arthur dayne
taking the winter rose crown for the
queen of love and beauty
he revealed his interest in lyanna stark
by passing over his wife princess
aelia of dorne and setting it in
lyanna's lap
eric stark later recalled that moment as
when all the smiles died
the next year rhaegar seemingly
kidnapped lyanna for reasons unknown
this act ultimately triggered robert's
rebellion and the downfall of the
targaryen dynasty
unknown to all liana had actually
desired to live with rhaegar
and they ran off together to the red
mountains of dorne
they stayed at a relatively small castle
rhaegar named the tower of joy
rhaegar arranged for the high septon to
grant him an annulment from his marriage
to aelia martel
then personally officiate his sacred
marriage to liana the same day
liana zelda's brother brandon then rode
to king's landing
to demand the return of his sister and
the death of rhaegar
king garys imprisoned him and when
rickard stark went south to ransom his
son he was imprisoned as well
the mad king then brutally executed both
of them by burning lord rickard alive
with wildfire
in front of the iron throne and baiting
brandon into strangling himself to death
in an effort to save his father
afterwards king carries demanded john
reign to send him the heads of eddard
stark and robert baratheon
john irene refused and instead raised
his banners in revolt
eric stark and lyanna betrothed robert
baratheon joined him to overthrow the
targaryen dynasty
this war became known as robert's
rebellion or the war of the usurper to
targaryen loyalists
to the confusion of many rhaegar's
location remained unknown during most of
the war
which lasted about a year as robert
baratheon's rebel army fought its way up
from storm's zen
through the reach and the riverlands and
then up to the trident
reagar was nowhere to be seen rhaegar
then suddenly returned to the royal
court at king's landing
to lead the crown's armies both sides
now mobilized the full might of their
forces
robert led his rebel army south composed
of baratheon's stark tully and
rainforces while rhaegar led the royal
army north to meet him
composed of the targaryen armies raised
from the crownlands
supplemented by another 10 000 from
dorne
rhaegar owned knight black plate armor
with the three-headed dragon
of house targaryen decorated in rubies
on its breastplate
and underneath the plate he wore golden
ring mail
rhaegar decorated his helm with gold
orange and red silken streamers
resembling flames
accompanying regard to of the kingsguard
barcelona luin martell
uncle of reger's wife felia on the way
rhaegar privately confided to barry
standett
after they won there would be many
changes at the royal court upon his
return
alluding that he intended to depose his
father for his crimes and instability
and try to restore peace with the great
houses of the realm
rhaegar and robert's forces finally
clashed at the climactic battle of the
trident
at the crossing of the king's road over
the river not far from dean and the
crossroads
rhaegar's army was fresh and slightly
larger
but roberts was more battle hardened and
they slowly gained ground
rhaegar and robert spotted each other
across the battlefield
and rode out to fight resulting in a
legendary duel as the battle dragged on
around them
rhaegar despite wounding robert was
struck down with a massive blow from
robert's warhammer
which scattered the rubies encrusted in
rhaegar's armor into the water
with their leader killed the targaryen
army collapsed
and the rebels were victorious with
rhaegar's death
the targaryen cause was doomed most of
their supporters had been fighting for
rhaegar
not the mad king so after he died most
either surrendered or switched sides
soon after rehgar's death most of his
family followed to an early grave
first was his first wife alia and their
children when they were brutally killed
by sir gregor clegane during the sack of
king's landing
meanwhile jaime lannister killed
rhaegar's father king aries to prevent
the wildfire plot
shortly before the sack rhaegar's
heavily pregnant mother quinrela had
been sent to safety on dragonstone
island
along with his younger brother viserys
not long after they arrived however
raila died giving birth to regards
posthumous younger sister
daenerys targaryen viserys and his
newborn sister then fled
into exile in the free cities across the
narrow sea
before robert's soldiers could arrive on
the island
lina stark did not survive much longer
than rhaegar either
she died from childbirth after having
given birth to her son
rhaegar's last child denair with her
last breath lyanna told eddard of her
secret marriage to rhaegar
and that their son's name was zagon
targaryen ultimately rhaegar still
remains a controversial figure
as his star crossed romance with lena
stark inadvertently led to his insane
father sparking a war with half of the
seven kingdoms
thousands died due to rhaegar's actions
or inaction
ending in his death the overthrow and
exile of what was left of his family
and indirectly resulted in the murder of
aelia
and their two children together what
could have possibly motivated rhaegar to
not only elope with lyna
but fight a war to keep their marriage
as sacred remains unknown
rhaegar valued his forthcoming child
with lyanna so much
that he even left champions of his
kingsguard behind in dorne to defend her
living legends who could have tipped the
balance if they had fought by his side
at the battle of the trident
perhaps it was his obsession with other
high prophecy
believing his son aegon who we know of
as jon snow was the prince that was
promised
there's so much we need to learn how did
rehgar and liana fall in love
and why did they decide to run away what
was that important to them to leave
without an explanation
making it seem like he kidnapped her
which put the seven kingdoms into the
state of chaos
which started the rebellion that ended
the targaryen dynasty
but that's all we have for now questions
without certain answers
questions which the game of thrones
pretty cool about history of how
targaryen house of the dragon will
answer
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace